dozens of parents and children have
spent the night in schools designated as
polling stations in the Spanish region
of Catalonia they were trying to prevent
police closing them down ahead of a
referendum on independence - to take
place tomorrow thousands of Catalan
independent supporters are gathering for
a final rally in Barcelona ahead of the
vote which has been declared illegal by
the government I will join now live from
the Drake by the Spanish Foreign
Minister Alfonso Dusty's Minister many
thanks for being with us and do you
think that the referendum will be going
ahead tomorrow no no it won't
there is no referendum there are no
voting premises there are no ballot
papers there are no authorities to check
you know the authenticity of the results
there may be some Shambo ting in places
and streets and certain places but some
but I don't think there is going to be a
referendum tomorrow no I mean you
suggest that there could be some sham
vote I mean estimates vary but we're
potentially going to be seeing millions
of people at casting a vote tomorrow
it's difficult to dismiss that it
dismissed that out of hand as something
illegal something that the Spanish
government doesn't have to be heed to
well listen that it is illegal it's not
the government that has said it is there
the courts the Constitutional Court you
know applying a constitution that by the
way is similar to the almost every
constitution in at least the Western
world whether there will be millions of
people coming out to vote we'll we'll
see but in any case the government has
already said that we are ready when
these defiance to the legal order and to
democracy by the way is over that
everyone is ready to sit down and talk
about the future and ways to accommodate
catalonia within the spanish state the
problem many people in the Catalan
region
see with all of this and indeed more
widely is that the Spanish Constitution
essentially says that the Spanish state
is indivisible this Constitution can
only be changed with two-thirds of the
individual component parts of Spain
coming together so it's difficult to see
a set of circumstances in which there
could be illegal votes or on Catalonian
independence ever being held well listen
the Constitution can be amended through
regular ordinary legal and democratic
procedures
it's foreseen so we certainly can can do
that and in any case I don't think you
would be ready to allow to a part of a
system to vote for the whole if you are
let's say in a co-op or condominium you
know a single tenant cannot do its will
and just decide to to disregard the
rules that apply to every Minister
Minister I mean Catalonia is something
rather bigger than a single tenant and
in a building isn't it I mean it's a
significant region in Spain it provides
20 percent of your GDP and let's be
honest about all of this it's the
financial loss that spin could endure it
as as a result of Catalonian
independence that's driving the
government's hand in all of this well no
really you know the Catalan government
current Catalan government has been
pushing a sort of PR campaign that base
disregarding the facts they are I think
the champions of alternative fact if you
look at the figures provided even
officially by the Catalan government
Catalunya a pays in taxes rather more or
less what it represents in terms of the
GDP of Spain and received back in an
amount which is similar to the portion
of the population which it represents in
the Spanish state so there is no way you
can claim that Spain
Rob's us or or oppresses us let's talk
about the practicalities of of the vote
going
had tomorrow even if only limited to a
number of polling stations there is a
real fear that we could be seeing
violence on the streets of Barcelona and
elsewhere I mean in circumstances where
a vote is pushed forward I mean can you
guarantee that the Spanish government
will not send the police send the army
and in a heavy-handed violent manner
well I think we have proven that already
the law enforcement officers are there
showing a lot of restraint acting in a
proportional way and if there is
violence it's not coming from them it's
even if it's not physical violence there
is intimidation there is harassment
coming out from groups that are
supporting the referendum so we will do
as much as we possibly can to ensure
that there is you know peaceful bro is
peaceful that there is no social
disturbance or unrest but I am afraid it
is not depending on us but we will do
all we possibly can but you say you
should do all that you possibly can and
where is the negotiation being with the
Catalan government and all of this there
has been absolutely no ground given
politically we know from the latest
polling that there is perhaps not as
things stand a majority for independence
you know this this approach by Mariano
Rajoy is only going to drive more people
to supporting the cause of Catalan
independence well I think everyone is
entitled to its own opinion I don't
think it is because of the position that
mr. aho and his government is taking
that people will be driven to support
the referendum in in Catalonia we have
already shown our readiness to enter
into a dialogue but of course it has to
be done without preconditions of
accepting a referenda that unfortunately
is not foreseen or authorized in the
Spanish Constitution and that's not a
matter of I mean it's the matter of
democracy
it's a matter of the rural law the the
democracy is not above the rule of law
democracy is guaranteed by the rule of
law yeah any referendum needs to have
you know legal legitimacy it also needs
to have political legitimacy and the
Catalonian government would suggest that
the support that they have in the
regional elections the polling data all
shows that there is a substantial body
of opinion there that believes that
catalonia should be independent I mean
can you perceive in the aftermath of
whatever happens tomorrow a better deal
for the Catalan region being on the
table well we certainly try and look at
a possible better deal as you say but
let me tell you that the reality is not
as a Catalan presenting presently that
reality um they are not being oppressed
Catalan is spoken you know
widely in Catalunya if there is someone
who has difficulties speaking their own
language is those Spanish speakers who
are still there and they have if you
read the statute of autonomy of
Catalonia and you look at the powers and
the competences that they have you would
see that you know hardly any other
autonomous region or federated state in
a federal state has many more powers
than Catalonia has let's Minister if we
can talk about another issue around
self-determination the vote taken by the
British public had to leave the European
Union it's a bumpy negotiating process
as far as we can tell I mean what is
your view in all of this I mean is the
European Union doing its utmost to try
to ensure first that Britain gets a bad
deal and second to discourage others
from following the UK's example no I
don't think so I mean we definitely
regret the result of the vote but we are
not out to punish the UK because it
would be tantamount to punishing
ourselves and I'm talking not only about
the European Union at large but Spain
particular so what we are after is a
successful brexit and we are working
towards that that goal so that's that's
our position
that's very clear and by a probability
of contagion I think again reality is
that some in countries that you may have
thought that would be tempted to follow
the British example such as Denmark or
Sweden the support for the EU has really
increased after the the brexit
referendum still it seems likely that
countries like Spain will be affected if
we reach the end of this negotiating
process and trade deals have not been
worked out I mean what are you saying to
Brussels as regards that that the lack
of progress which means it seems
unlikely we're going to be talking UK EU
trade deals until you know sometime next
year well you know we are definitely
unite United behind our negotiator we
want to make sure that we have a
successful and orderly exit of the UK
but we are very much interested in
keeping a strong relation and have a you
know a trade deal that is good for for
both parties we have you know in the UK
is the first country of destination of
our foreign investment over 17 million
Brits come to Spain every year so I mean
we are definitely we will be definitely
committed to ensuring that this ends out
with a success and they will have to be
some transitional deal but we will work
and I'm pretty sure that we will come to
an agreement that is satisfactory for
both parties and Minister whilst we have
here I'm wondering what the Spanish
government's position is at the moment
on the self-determination of the people
of Gibraltar was the same you know we we
feel that the existence of a Connolly
colony I'm sorry in
in Europe in the 21st century is as an
anachronism we definitely want to you
know get back our territorial integrity
but we are not out you know to to make
it impossible to have an agreement
between the UK and the EU we are not
going to make it more difficult because
of the question of Gibraltar and our
aspirations is that in the end we can
find a solution that is acceptable for
everyone yeah it's just I do see that
some people will see a certain parallel
between the situation in Catalonia and
the situation in Gibraltar the
overwhelming majority of the people of
Gibraltar wish to remain part of the
United Kingdom for you it appears it's
the territorial integrity of Spain as
with Catalonia that appears to be the
most important thing not the views of
those who live there no it's it's the
the opinion of everyone who is involved
and who live in those territories is
very important but there those things
cannot be you know there are no
parallels in the in the two situations
one comes from you know from the 18th
century is it's a remnant of bygone
times it's a matter of colonialism and
in anyway I have told you already that
we want to convince those who live there
I think we have offered a solution that
is could give them the best of both
worlds but if they cannot we will go
ahead and we'll look at ways how we can
put an end to this Alacran ISM Alphonso
Dusty's many thanks for joining us here
on Sky News which appreciated